hallo lukat ricken porno polo wäre ja
ich habe mich so ein bisschen dem thema
des heutigen videos angepasst und zwar
reagieren sondern ich heute endlich mal
wieder aufhört mir was erwartest du von
der folge einen potenziellen ehemann
sieht aus wie norman hat die schon
tausend mal gesagt bedeute möhren darin
sein zimmer aufräumen
du machst dir gar nicht erreicht könnte
wahr zu sein ist dass die mutter das ist
die freundin
[Musik]
ich sage freundin was hast du unter
mutter lass deinen scheiß dich an mir ab
alles klar was kann ich tun kannst das
zimmer selbst aufräumen nicht erst mal
ich bin nicht der alte ich bin deine
mutter mehr reiche
sandra kennt ja auch jede folge
auswendig wie du donnerstag zum
stammtisch gehst und wen kann ich mich
voll rein
ich bin auch sonst die donnerstag das
eben dem stammtisch ich hab keine
freunde
das schüttelt denn sein hier
nein nein das ist der könig wortwörtlich
das macht laune
die große ich frage mich immer so ein
bisschen wohnen die da wirklich oder ist
das eine gemietete wohnung hat dass die
gemietete wohnung dann tue mir aber auch
immer die nachbarn leid wenn sowas war
gedreht wir es nicht so aus das ist
jetzt so voll die traurige musik oder 8
[Gelächter]
das sieht aus wie der mond elversberg
auf dem rücken wie siehst du das so die
mitte ist so komplett weiß und links und
rechts und wir wollten seine mutti gibt
eine aus heute freunde dafür da garnicht
moody s benehmen seiner mutter gegenüber
ist beschämend ja aus sie habe ich
vermisst
das war eigentlich immer eine andere
programm ist jetzt neu auch der
hintergrund ist neu nein das ist beides
nicht neu so sandra du hast doch das
hilft mir habe aber ich hab alles dreht
sich scheinbar nur um seine freunde und
die anerkennung in der gruppe das ist
schlimm wie schlimm es ist außen opfer
hier geht es um die anerkennung seiner
freunde weiß es nicht bekommen hast
kasse ist keine freude mit lukas es muss
ja auch nicht peinlich sein
ich kann hier eine halbe freundin von
mir abgeben alles gute da hingehe und
bist kannst du mir schon geben davon
zurück
es ist peinlich zu sagen und sowas so
dass meine schwester ich durfte einmal
am liebsten abreißen
es gibt so als aufgeregt erholten damals
nicht gegessen
bin ich auch als ich oder sogar egal
jetzt schilder und trägt man erst mal
ein bier alkohol ist klar ich muss noch
lernen sind dinge die du gesagt hast ich
muss mal lernen muss aber andauern
vögeln menschenrechte sind sämtlich
abgestoßen nicht jeder kann sich bei
mama zu hause durchfüttern lassen ticker
das gar nicht die wahrheit keine scheiße
da sagst du dicker oder dicker
ich sag auch digger eine zeitlang dicker
an gewohnt wegen geyer und fabi und so
die gardinger oder
ich sage auch wieder das denn alles klar
sabrina ausgeht er seine freundin die
sieht aus wie eine elf von 10 für ihn
kann ich vielleicht nach berlin klappen
oder nachts ist es mir scheissegal was
die alte sagen
corona hallo krass das ist grundsätzlich
sehr viel dass er oder aber auch noch
bruder arbeiten kinder mit mitte 20 noch
zu hause wohnen muss das nicht immer ein
problem sein aber ein offensichtlicher
machen was sie aus diesen salat du bist
das größte problem ist der umgang zu
hause scheint völlig respektlos und
außer kontrolle
[Musik]
daran hat gestern also dem auto saßen
gesagt wenn sie irgendwann mal
überfallen werden sollte da wenn
irgendein mörder oder einen verbrecher
zu jagen kommen sie wird einfach nur
lachen
ich kann auch mal beißend oder es auch
sein sender seine würstchen oder nicht
der motor da ja wenn du doch
hast du dir nach hause einlädt und gibt
es im essen von dir dann fragst du auch
nicht kann ich auch was haben oder schon
[Musik]
das war echt zu bild das sich den traum
von dir mit vom typen gemeinsam ein
fußballfan der muss aber aussehen wie
nie mo
das wahrscheinlich das ganze essen was
die mutter gekocht hat ja komm wir das
auch in schiltern kühlschrank bestimmt
für den vater nach der nachtschicht oder
so jaja lukas hast du das schon getan
hab ich nichts sandra wirst du auf deine
familie das los nicht genug leute nicht
verstanden ich hab dich rausgeschmissen
recht erinnerst du dich aus sie
behandelt seine mutter wirklich kleiner
see rossi heißt sondern mir schon mal
eine mischung aus asien und osten
schreibst du als sie eigentlich so oder
so mit zwei es ja viele stand auch mit
eines wegen asozial
thomas warum jetzt aber im endeffekt
nehmen
so der sinn von hilfe ist ja zu zeigen
hey da sind einfach leute die jungen
pleite verzweifelt war und es sind ja
auch nur schauspieler aber die wollen ja
immer noch irgendwie was gutes dann
zeigen am ende und die haben sich
entwickelt und keine ahnung war es am
mittwoch die man da so leid obwohl es
nur schauspiel ist
ja mit tun er die kartoffeln hat war
diese lecker sind ist mein freund china
und wir haben ein bisschen was vor so
wie sophie du verstehst du
gerade die ja wie er seine mutter hoch
nimmt das geht ja gar nicht klar
eventuell sei
die wand erinnert mich an wasser an
wasser an der stelle wird mir das
heutige wieder ist allerdings auch
beenden meine lieben freunde wenn euch
diese hilfe mehr action gefallen hat
dann schreibt uns gern mal unten in die
kommentare sandra und ich sind gleich
übrigens ab 19 uhr live auf youtube.com
schrägstrich in luque rudi reagieren auf
234 youtube videos und spielen danach in
astana steht dieses spiel zum ersten mal
deswegen stehen wir zusammen im stream
also schaut auf jeden fall vorbei meine
lieben freunde ansonsten würde ich das
als kohle